comenzamos directo a y hoy conectamos
con lisboa donde hoy terminó la
conferencia de la onu sobre los océanos
después de cinco días de discusiones los
países pactaron una declaración cuyo
cumplimiento no es obligatorio el texto
hizo un llamado a actuar para proteger
los mares y las aguas internacionales
aunque las dificultades permanecen como
la falta de financiación hablamos a esta
hora con marina colorado en nuestra
mirada especial a la capital portuguesa
para cubrir la cumbre marina buenas
noches para ustedes cuéntenos qué es el
pacto y qué es lo que dice
la declaración de lisboa es un documento
meramente político que no tiene ninguna
validez legal es decir que todo lo que
está ahí escrito es de cumplimiento
sugerido el texto titulado nuestro
océano a nuestro futuro y nuestra
responsabilidad es un llamado a la
acción más que nada la declaración
reconoce que el océano es fundamental
para la vida en el planeta y la clave
para frenar la crisis climática sin
embargo el texto lamenta el fracaso
colectivo al no haber conseguido varios
de los objetivos relacionados con el
cuidado de los mares y de los océanos
además ofrece disculpas por la inacción
mostrada hasta el momento el objetivo
último de la conferencia era realmente
conectar proyectos ideas y personas con
los fondos necesarios para llevar a cabo
esos planes y en eso según los
organizadores ha sido un éxito rotundo
con 700 compromisos voluntarios de
inversión pública y privada
ahora los ojos están puestos en nueva
york' que en agosto podrá aprobar un
acuerdo vinculante para proteger las
aguas internacionales y en canadá donde
en diciembre se decidirá sobre la
protección del 30% de mares y tierras
antes del 2030 todo esto además de la
cumbre climática con 27 en egipto en el
mes de noviembre
2022 ha sido bautizado como un súper año
para los océanos ya veremos si realmente
es así
bueno pero cuáles son las dificultades
para cumplir esos pactos y que se viene
para los próximos meses
todos coincidieron en lo mismo se sabe
que hay que hacer como se debe hacer
pero el mayor reto es la falta de
financiación el objetivo de desarrollo
sostenible 14 referente al océano que es
uno de los 17 objetivos en la hoja de
ruta de la onu para un futuro próspero
para personas y naturaleza es el que
menos dinero recibe esto a pesar de
referirse al recurso que cubre el 70%
del planeta y no es que el dinero no
exista sino que se está dirigiendo a
otras industrias como por ejemplo con
subsidios a las petroleras durante rueda
de prensa esta mañana le pregunté al
enviado especial de la onu para los
océanos peter thompson de la isla de
fiyi que cuánto dinero haría falta para
alcanzar a hacer todo lo que se necesita
hacer y él me dijo que la cifra alcanza
los millones de dólares es decir
millones de millones de dólares y
teniendo en cuenta que hace 13 años que
los países más industrializados llevan
prometiendo 100 mil millones de dólares
para mitigar y adaptarse a los efectos
climáticos al ayudar a los países en
vías de desarrollo pues no aparece y que
se alcance la cifra necesaria para poder
financiar todos estos planes que tienen
para proteger los océanos gracias marina
por toda esta información nosotros
continuamos en directo américa